fin juin ce centre médical bien connue
des trappistes du centre-ville va fermer
un centre ouvert depuis de nombreuses
années les praticiens ont vendu leur
local où on ne peut pas parler à trappes
de désert médical quand même parce que
on a un autre centre communal de santé
on à l'hôpital a aussi tous les autres
médecins
le problème de fond c'est dans ce
secteur urbain on va définir comme
jaurès gars ça fait un vide important un
vide important dans ce secteur qu'il
faut donc comblé la ville en partenariat
avec la faculté de médecine de saint
quentin en yvelines l agence régionale
de santé lance un recrutement de
médecins les locaux de l'ancienne pmi
anne-frank peuvent être mis à
disposition de 150 m² avec une entrée
directe sur l'avenue paul vaillant
couturier placé en plein centre précise
le maire transformée pour l'occasion en
vrp
on est en train de monter finalement un
recrutement de deux ou trois médecins
généralistes on espère aujourd'hui j'ai
une nouvelle positive mais qui n'est pas
définitivement quoi mais en tout cas les
démarches commença à bien s'enregistrer
j'espère que donc d'ici le 1er ou ou
juin juillet on aura trouvé donné cinq
honda couleurs avec beaucoup de plaisir
et qu'on on aidera
à démarrer un aider à démarrer cela
passe notamment par la possibilité de
négocier le loyer un centre médical qui
ferme le centre municipal de santé qui
lui va déménager
actuellement situé au square guy forget
il va s'implanter dans le quartier des
merisiers dans un local neuf avec du
matériel renouvelé la 11 médecins et qui
travaillent là qu'ils sont sont
relations dans un réseau les travaux se
terminent le centre devrait ouvrir le 26
mars en raison du déménagement le centre
yves farge lui sera fermé du 19 au 25
mars